President Biden's border policies being
blamed for a horrific loss of life in
Texas at least 51 migrants found dead
from the sweltering heat stacked on top
of one another in an abandoned
tractor-trailer that had no working air
conditioning or even water in what
appears to be one of the most deadly
incidents of human smuggling across the
southern border three suspects are in
custody following the terrible Discovery
every month there's been record-breaking
numbers at the border and Border agents
constantly say they're overwhelmed by
The Surge and they do not feel supported
Texas governor Greg Abbott tweeting this
these deaths are on Biden they are a
result of his deadly open border
policies and Senator Ted Cruz tweeting
how many more people have to die before
Dems give a damn the White House firing
back at critics
the fact of the matter is the border is
closed which is in part why you see
people trying to make this dangerous
Journey using smuggling networks we are
going to stay focused on the facts uh
and uh and making sure that uh we hold
uh these uh Smugglers accountable
all right Jesse is it fair to blame
President Biden's policies I I believe
it is fair he's a snob from Delaware he
doesn't even consider Texas a part of
the country he thinks it's our gas
station that's where they killed Kennedy
it's where they kill the ozone layer and
they're a bunch of Neanderthals that's
how he really feels about Texas he's
been to China
in the last 40 years more times than
he's been to our Southern border and I
just don't feel like he feels great
affection towards the state of Texas and
it's a mass casualty event 40 Mexican
Nationals are dead 51 51. if that were
Japanese
that that were British Nationals Joe
Biden would have been on the phone with
their leader Biden has not called the
president of Mexico at all
AOC flew down to the border to cry on a
fence because Donald Trump put adults
and children in separate facilities as
he was required to do under law
there's all these people dead AOC hasn't
said anything about it and she's
probably busy watching the January 6th
hearings
the media doesn't even ask Joe Button
about the border and so Joe Biden
doesn't talk about the border the media
doesn't cover it because they don't want
to go all the way down there it's hard
to get to it's hot it's dusty and it's
not glamorous to do stand-ups down there
so it's almost like it doesn't exist
here's the solution
we have to bring all the factories that
we have in China and put them in
northern Mexico we have a trade deal
with Mexico
that's where their jobs will be that
solves the China problem solves the
immigration problem put the factories
in Colombia too we have a trade pact
with the Colombians as well
I think that solves all the problems and
he should do that and if you're not
going to secure the border and if you're
just going to throw money at a corrupt
Honduran or El Salvadorian president
that's the only way you're actually
going to get the migration under control
judge what um like at your perspective I
would like your perspective on the
prosecution of the suspects that they
have already apprehended but there's got
to be a connection right so they have
the three people there but there's
obviously a chain that goes all the way
back well I mean what you do in a
situation like that and and God bless
California they let these guys out as
soon as they arrested them I mean these
guys who have all the information
um a lot of them on Fentanyl and these
guys in particular
um you get information from them you
pull them hard and they can give you
information as to smuggling whether it's
human smuggling or drug smuggling they
know what's going on here
um and you just go up the chain you
scare them you scare them you scare
their families the feds do it every day
but I got to tell you something I think
in a bizarre our way I think the Biden
Administration could turn this thing
around and say see the border is closed
we told you the border is secured see
they had to smuggle them in like this
and they're dying to come in here's the
bottom line that contradicts all of that
the president is in the United States
Supreme Court fighting the remain in
Mexico policy he doesn't want the
illegals to remain in Mexico he is
fighting title 42. he wants to open the
border the the president fought with the
governor Abbott because Governor Abbott
was inspecting the the 18-wheelers as
they came in and then everybody brought
a lot of criticism in said he was
slowing down traffic Governor Abbott
could have found these people before
they actually died but no we had to stop
him and so what this Administration is
doing is they're laying out the welcome
mat every day in terms of what they do
so they can tell me until the cows come
home the borders secure that the borders
closed and they're lying to all of us
they're busy flying them in bussing them
into the interior they're housing
unaccompanied migrant children smuggled
in by the cartels that they're
accompanying and facilitating hiring 800
Americans to staff a facility they're
quietly erasing immigration cases giving
de facto amnesty to one million illegals
I mean the goal for them should be to
stop the human trafficking and the drug
smuggling but they're doing just the
opposite so why is he trying so hard to
fail and why is it that he let it get
this way is he that afraid of the
progressives why
Geraldo um take it from there wherever
you want well I I totally I I want to
say that it's so easy for Senator Cruz
or Governor Abbott to say oh Biden's
fault bidenfold Biden's fault uh
the fact of the matter is first of all
let me Express sincere condolences I
feel nothing but grief over this
horrible mass murder that's what it was
this is a this is a mass murder I am
outraged at these perpetrators I want
them prosecuted to the full extent of
the law the judge is right you squeeze
them you walk your way up the chain you
find out at least maybe you get the
Mexicans involved in tracking down these
cartel this cannot we cannot abide 51
murders
I blame President Biden I do think that
his compassion has backfired at the
border I do think that as obnoxious as
Trump's moves were they were more
effectives in dissuading them from
coming and taking this perilous journey
and I think
as we approach July 4th
what you have to recognize is the
brutality of this evidence of how badly
these people want to be in the United
States of America they risk everything
even their very lives they voluntarily
stuff themselves into that semi only to
choke to death in sweltering heat and
it's interesting bill malusian is one of
our reporters he's been there at the
border along with Griff Jenkins and many
others Casey Siegel but I was talking to
Bill Malaysia not too long ago and he
sees no other reporters there and he's
been there for months and we report on
this every day and I watched one I
watched one Nightly News broadcast every
single night just to see and I never see
any coverage of the Border but this
story they would cover well this story
you kind of have to cover but it also
sadly obviously it's devastating not
that surprising because it's a complete
disaster down there it is a humanitarian
crisis anyone who's paying attention to
immigration at all knows that it's also
such a disaster that when they said see
look the border is closed see this
proves it's closed I would just love to
follow that up with being like okay like
does this look good does this look like
this is going well because nothing in
terms of their immigration policy is
going well including legal immigration
when you talk about people who want to
come to this country and get work visas
and work and go the legal way they
wasted 66 000 of those visas last year
despite the fact that our labor market
was so tight that are expired and they
can never get them back so the whole
system is a complete disaster and
they're scrambling and anyone who's
paying attention
they can figure that out even the
slightest bit of attention so I guess
the only strategy that would make sense
is to try to get people not to pay
attention hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now